[Music]
hello thank you for coming we are here
today really to talk about something
that was really pretty momentous and
that was this you could ask yourself
whether the landing of the moon and
watching a human walking on the moon was
the most iconic part of the 20th century
the most iconic moment I want to argue
or suggest you or give you an
interpretation of this event that
suggests despite the huge expense
despite the enormous questions about
whether we should have been doing that
at all there's something here which I
think was important and unique unique to
when it was actually taking place
something that couldn't happen now
couldn't happen in the same way because
when some of us me included were young
enough to remember watching this very
strange scene looking at this fuzzy TV
picture that looked like what would now
count as one of the internal scans of
your organs you know you're trying to
say is that a leg is that a food I can't
quite see what's going on there was
something about that that was made
possible at that time because it was
shared throughout the world so that
meant it was a televisual age and it
meant it was an age at which you could
give live information and feed it around
the world so let's concentrate on that
there was something particularly
important I think about the moon landing
because it made us realize we were not
just always going to be on this planet
it gave us a sense for the first time
that we could actually exist maybe live
but certainly we could be occupy beyond
another another planet another part of
another world and that was very very
special and we'd already got this
growing sense of ourselves from the
Apollo missions you remember this famous
photograph Earthrise which was taken by
Bill Anders on Apollo 8 and the nice
thing that was
said about Apollo 8 was they went to
discover the moon and they found the
earth because famously they were just
preparing to go into moon orbit and
suddenly looking out of the command
module and earth saw this beautiful
scene of the blue globe the blue planet
rising there they rush to get a camera
they photographed it and then everybody
back on earth suddenly understood what
they understood how incredibly remote
but also how incredibly fragile our
situation was and it was a way of seeing
ourselves that we hadn't had we could
imagine it but we hadn't actually seen
it and there was something important
about being able to witness this to see
something very far away
and remember when Cernan Lovell and
Anders were looking at this they knew
that every other human being there was
was there that was a very remarkable
feat that was something that they were
witnessing that was something that was
important because they stood in for all
of us in giving us this opportunity to
view ourselves in this way and as many
of you know a lot of the Apollo
astronauts subsequently became huge
environmental campaigners they became
campaigners about protecting the planet
about looking after our ecology at
realizing how fragile it was how unique
it was how special it was and it seems
as though quite often we understand a
problem like the problems now of climate
change in the environment but to be able
to perceive for yourself the problem to
be able to actually clap eyes on it
that's really special that does move
minds and hearts and changes things I
think and as we said it was a mass
participation event it was estimated
there were about 500 million people
watching this event across the world now
when people think about a very
significant event where were you when X
happened it's usually a natural disaster
an act of terrorism an assassination
but here was a an event that was a happy
event
he was an event that people could be
celebrating they could be proud of they
could feel some sense that this was a
human achievement so to do that seems to
be something which really marks it out
is very different from say remembering
the Twin Towers collapsing around brings
seeing Martha Luton Luther King having
been assassinated so those are joy in
participating in this and of course it
all got going it got ramped up and it
got fast when Jack Kennedy made his very
famous speech setting out the challenge
which he made on a university campus and
the the beautiful thing that's often
neglected is the rest of the content of
that speech we all remember this the
famous line we choose to go to the moon
not because it's easy but because it's
hard but look at what he's saying here
he said there is no strife no prejudice
no national conflict in outer space as
yet so therefore something that United
as a because the hazards of outer space
are hostile to us all all humans we face
that collectively its conquest deserves
the best of all mankind and its
opportunity for peaceful cooperation may
never come again now that that idea of
peaceful cooperation in the space race
is often thought to be rather ironic and
not entirely sincere given that we know
that Kennedy and many people in the
administration were motivated by a
technological race against the Soviet
Union with the idea being if we showed
in the West that we had you know
technological preeminence this would be
defeating and running down and
eventually ruling against the idea that
they would continue to be a nuclear arms
race that the Soviet Union could compete
with us in but that's not actually what
happened I don't know how many of you
know this but at the stage in 62 where
Kennedy was making this speech he
actually asked Khrushchev do you want to
come in with us on this do you want to
join us
in trying to land someone on the moon
and Khrushchev said we will take them
there you bring them back and that
wasn't how NASA saw it that's that new
the hardest thing was to come back he
knew that the Soviets probably had the
technology to go there but also
Khrushchev was doing a calculation he
thought it's not in my interest when I
want to show the strength and the
prowess of the Soviet Union's not my
interest to go in with the u.s. here but
Kennedy was interested and he asked not
once but twice to the Soviet Union to
join and this idea that is because space
is hostile to all of us it's a challenge
to all humans it's something which
allows us to think of somewhere where
there isn't even conflict in outer space
and he says isn't conflict yet and we
know now we've got the current president
of the United States trying to think of
his you know his missile fleet and his
space fleet for destructive and
aggressive purposes it's very prescient
I think the whole speech is very
prescient he says to be sure to be sure
we are behind behind the Soviets in
technology and we will be behind for
some time in manned flight but we do not
intend to stay behind and in this decade
we shall make up and move ahead so yes
he was setting that challenge to his own
country to his own technicians to do
this and then famously he said we choose
to go to the moon we choose to go to the
moon not be in this decade and do the
other things not because they are easy
but because they are hard because that
goal will serve to organize and measure
the best of our energies and skills
because that challenge is one that we
are willing to accept and we are
unwilling to postpone and one which we
intend to win and the others too but he
knew that this required a great deal of
support from the public as well as from
the politicians here's the thing you
have to remember again it's a moment the
landing on the moon the Apollo mission
it was publicly funded this wasn't about
private commercial interest this wasn't
about
very wealthy people like Elon Musk
thinking well I'll use some of my
enormous capital to make this book this
was a publicly funded publicly supported
project run by and with the help of many
public institutions but he knows that
it's going to ask a lot he says if I
were to say my fellow citizens that we
shall send to the moon twenty four
thousand miles away from the control
station in Houston a giant rocket more
than three hundred feet tall the length
of this football field made of new ally
alloys some of which have not yet been
invented he knew that you are actually
setting huge technological challenges to
do something they couldn't even do and
think of doing there and then standing
heat and stresses more than have ever
been experienced with a precision better
than the finest watch interesting it's
the watch analogy and not computer
analogy at that stage carrying all the
equipment we need for guidance control
communications food and survival on an
untried mission to an unknown celestial
body and then return it safely to earth
re-entering the atmosphere of speeds
over 25,000 miles per hour causing heat
about half of that of the temperature of
the Sun almost as hot as it is here
today in Houston he reminds them he
brings them back to where they are to
the moment but he's actually inviting
them to say you know be inspired by this
see what science will have to do and he
was right to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit a I
dot TV for more debates and talks from
the world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas